mexico's been grappling for years with
how to regulate this
marijuana it's been illegal for decades
while a war against drugs has raged
now a new law approved by the senate but
which still has to go through congress
proposes legalizing production and
consumption
with quite a lot of restrictions
adults would be able to buy up to 28
grams of pot
and cultivate full plants for personal
use it could also be imported
and exported with a license this grower
now producing illegally is cautiously
optimistic
i decided to grow because i'm a consumer
first and i think that
right now the conditions in which
marijuana is produced and distributed in
our country
is very violent and very corrupt and
that's the key question
will legalizing marijuana affect
mexico's cartels and gangs who currently
run the business
the common consensus is no cannabis
production is just a small part of their
portfolio
which also includes meth fentanyl
cocaine and other rackets like extortion
have a look at this these cannabis
plants are actually being grown right in
front of mexico
senate by marijuana activists who are
trying to raise awareness of what's
going on
and they have another big question and
it's this
will poorer communities in the rural
hills of mexico
that currently grow their crop for the
narcos now get the chance to go
legal and on paper under this law it
seems like they will
because 40 of the licenses to grow
marijuana in the first five years of
legalization
are reserved for them but in practice
things could work differently in the
mountains imminent risk
that if you as a local peasant for
instance say i will only produce
legally now i want to make a living
in illicit and legal terms that you will
not get away with that because there is
a frank power of organized criminal
groups in those areas
and the most likely scenario is
unfortunately
that if you have a new lucrative market
coming into play that they will try
and probably succeed in getting their
hands on the new proceeds on the new
profits
the fear of marijuana activists is that
the law will actually
only help international corporations get
into the mexican market
and sell to richer urban consumers while
elsewhere the street corner business
continues as normal
but in a socially conservative country
where any talk of drug legalization is
deeply controversial
both senators and advocates hope this
could be the start of change
john holman al jazeera mexico city